[Music]
hi and welcome to serverless migration
station i'm wesley from google cloud
joined by martin and porter the train to
help you modernize your apps and use the
latest features from serverless happy to
be here again with what are we doing
today in this module we're covering app
engine blob store a handy service
managing file uploads and downloads for
your apps portal will take you on a
journey adding blob store to a sample
app then migrated to cloud storage next
time well just like the other migrations
we've covered while porter does help
users get from point a to point b we
need to first take a detour to
reacquaint folks with app engine blob
store so this video won't feature any
migrating at all you've done it again
wes more non-migration content in a
migration video series why yeah the
current sample app doesn't use blob
store so let's add its usage to the
module 0 baseline app and then migrate
it to cloud storage ahead in module 16.
that makes sense tell me more well we're
going to begin with the module 0
baseline app the original baseline app
for all of our migrations
i've done some of these migrations with
you already but we typically start from
the module one app where we've already
migrated frameworks from
web app 2 to flask
why we're starting with module 0
which is still using web app great
observation not only do we have to start
with web app 2 but blobster even has a
dependency on web app app engine's
original framework when it launched
don't worry though when we swap out
blobstore with cloud storage in module
16 we'll also move to flask at the same
time
sounds good
now this migration appears to be all
python 2. what about python 3 developers
good question unfortunately
neither web app nor web app 2 are
supported by the python 3 runtime once
you migrate to another framework and add
app engine's python 3 support for
bundled services then you can stay on
blob store oh so you mean it's possible
to have a python 3 flask app using
blobstore yes using bundle services like
blob store or memcache in second
generation apps and runtimes is covered
in module 17. the goal of this module 15
video is to add use of store paving the
way for the module 16 migration to cloud
storage
okay so i get we're adding blob store
today earlier you said we're migrating
from blob store to cloud storage plus
web app to flask
what else are we going to do in module
16. well in that next video we're going
to do a total of four migrations you
already pointed out blob store to cloud
storage web app 2 to flask but we're
also repeating the module 2 migration
from app engine adb to cloud ndb and
finally we're upgrading to python 3. in
fact the module 16 app is both python 2
and 3 compatible cool i'm looking
forward to that
back on today's topic what blob store
usage are we adding to the sample app
yeah currently the app registers all
visits upon page load but we're updating
it to ask users to associate an artifact
like a picture with a visit
users can either upload one or click
skip after that they get to the most
recent visit page just like normal
future visitors will see links for all
recent visits with files and can click
to view if desired
okay i have to be honest i haven't used
app engine blob store before can i
implement it myself while you're showing
us on screen sure thing clone the repo
or downloaded zip file and go to the
module 0 folder as that's where we'll
start if you want to do this by hand
with me now or on your own time follow
the module 15 code codelab links to both
are down below so let's go to the
computer now and do this
module 0 was a long time ago so let's
ensure that that baseline app still
works get the code from the repo
it should just have these three files
you see here then use g-cloud app deploy
to upload to app engine once you confirm
it works meaning it registers your visit
and shows the 10 most recent visits we
can add some functionality to support
the blob store service
module 0 uses the web app 2 framework
that comes with app engine which uses
the default django templating system to
bring our port to flask we're swapping
in the jinja 2 templating system instead
but we're staying on web app for now
because blobstore depends on it
update the app.yaml config file to
reference the built-in version of jinja
2.
note this is not its latest version but
the latest available on python 2 app
engine servers the codelab has more info
but suffices to say just add these lines
for now
next let's update the imports by adding
ginger to blob store and the web app
handlers for blob store because we're
now using jinja 2 we can remove the
django template import from webapp
since it's not the default templating
system we need to add a new base handler
to help rendering templates so add this
class and its pair of methods
our app will support blobstore uploads
so we need a new property in our data
model to reflect the uploaded file
calling it file blob
in store visits we need to store the
blob store key in file blob so make that
change
finally since the blob key is in the
data store it will be returned in any
queries we make so fetch visits stays
the same
scrolling down the most significant
changes take place in this part of
main.py
to support file uploads as well as
rendering uploaded files we need new
upload and download handlers for blob
store
regardless of whether the user uploads a
file or clicks skip it will post to
slash upload and goes to the upload
handler the handler stores the visit
info including a blob key if a file was
uploaded or none if not
it then reposts to slash hence the http
307 redirect you web developers out
there know that 302 and 303 change the
request to get so we need 307 because it
preserves the verb
when users click the artifact link on
most recent visits page it issues a get
request to slash view with the blob key
the view blob handler extracts the blob
key and sends the blob down if it exists
in case someone tries to fetch something
else by manipulating the url or request
a blob that's no longer in blob store a
404 is returned
the main handler needs to be updated for
both uploads and downloads for an
initial get request we need to show the
artifact upload form so
blobstore.createupload url is used to
call slash upload for the form response
on the other side when the upload
handler 307 reposts back to home
we fetch the most recent visits
including any artifact links and render
them in the template
finally the new routes for the upload
and download handlers are added to the
web app 2 app instantiation
the application code is now updated so
we have to implement the same changes
visually in the web template
in the first part of the template we
need to add the file upload form the
form action is the slash upload url and
there's a regular submit button along
with the skip button the form is only
shown if an upload url is present
otherwise we show the most recent visits
like before
the original part of the template
rendering the most recent visits is
updated to link to a visit artifact
along with its blob key if present and
none otherwise
those are all the changes needed in the
web template the final step is to create
a new templates folder and put
index.html into it as that is jinja2's
preferred default
with all those changes made upload to
the cloud with gcloud app deploy and see
how the app has changed when hitting the
in-app initially instead of the most
recent visits you should see the file
upload form
upload something or click skip
now you're brought to the familiar most
recent visits page but with one big
difference visits with upload files
feature a link to render that artifact
and that's it you've now added use of
blob store to your sample app
congratulations but hold on before
rejoining martin there's one more thing
as cloud storage matured as a product
the goal was to migrate blob store there
one of the features to support this
transition was to give developers the
ability to specify a cloud storage
bucket
you can see in the main handler how the
call to create the blob store upload url
can take such a bucket name as an
additional parameter since app engine
defaults to a bucket named after your
app's default url you know project
id.appspot.com we use the app identity
api to explicitly use that same bucket
name in the call while that is the
default know that you can now change it
if desired
okay that's it what do you think of
blobstore martin
wow blobstore looks like a cool feature
and i like how in the last part you
showed how it already integrates with
cloud storage
since i'm still new to blobstore are
there any docks you can point me to of
course start with the blob store
overview for specific details also check
out the blob store reference docs for
python 2 and 3 as well as accessing
bundled services like blobstore in
python 3. see the links in the
description below
very good i'll take a look so i can be
ready for the migration in module 16.
are there any docs i can review to look
ahead yes to help plan for all those
migrations in module 16 we've got links
to the cloud stores migration guide the
docs for cloud storage itself and a link
to the module 16 code lab so you can get
a head start before hitting the video
great i've got some stuff to read and
try out before then thanks so much wes
yes and thank you for joining us on all
these journeys to help you modernize
your serverless apps this is wesley on
behalf of martin and porter and we'll
see you at the next migration station or
on another serverless expedition soon
till then happy travels
[Music]